-Guys, as I said before, this
week, the U.N. General Assembly
with leaders coming in from
all over the world is happening.
They're gonna give speeches.
They're gonna meet each other.
But sometimes, when
you meet new people,
it can be hard to break the ice,
which is why a lot
of leaders come prepared
with their very own "getting
to know you" icebreakers.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Icebreakers."
-♪ "Tonight Show Icebreakers" ♪
-First up, we have British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson.
His icebreaker is, "Which fork
do you use to comb your hair?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah.
A nice icebreaker.
Gets you into the conversation.
Next up, we have
Latvian President Egils Levits.
His icebreaker is,
"Hi, my friends call me
'Latvian Wolf Blitzer.'"
-Good one.
-It's just icebreaking.
-Yeah, just break the ice.
-Next up, is
Finnish President Niinisto.
His icebreaker is, "Sorry,
you might not recognize me
without my Joker makeup."
That's interesting.
It's an icebreaker.
-Yeah.
-Here is Prime Minister
Bennett of Israel.
His icebreaker is, "Do you like
my resting kissy face?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Smooching ]
-Up next, here is
U.S. President Joe Biden.
-Oh.
-His icebreaker is,
"You remind me
of my buddy, Jasper.
He invented the wheel."
-That's his icebreaker?
Wow.
-Next is Estonian President
Kaljulaid.
Her icebreaker is,
"You appear weak.
I bore of this."
[ Laughter and applause ]
next up, we have
Prime Minister Modi of India.
His icebreaker is, "Why does
Macy's keep offering me
a part-time job
for the holidays?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's a good icebreaker.
-Yeah.
And finally, here is Brazilian
President Jair Bolsonaro.
His icebreaker is,
"I'm unvaxxed, sashed,
and ready to get trashed."
That's all we have for
"Tonight Show Icebreakers."